Good morning, good evening or even very
good afternoon depending on which part
of the world you're in. My name is
Tavanglava and I'm here to speak about
an interesting topic. I'm going to speak
about my name a bit later just to make
sure that everybody understands what it
actually means. But I think the key
thing to understand more than anything
is what does AI mean to all of us? And I
think it's a question that all of us
have been asking ourselves quite
recently where we see AI is not just a
conversation that we're having in tech
rooms or in tech meetups, but it's
actually starting to be a conversation
in some weird places. Are we looking at
the transformation of the world? But
more importantly for us Africans, the
transformation of the continent.
Spoiler alert, some of concepts of AI or
rather AI in itself is not a new topic.
In about 1950, concepts such as neural
networks which are fundamental to AI,
concepts such as machine learning in the
1980s and of course very recently the
deep learning
conversations. But we're starting to
have different arguments now where we
used to brag about generative AI and how
it provides all of these things for us.
Now we're looking at a different aspect
of AI where we starting to speak about
agentic AI and what it provides or
rather what decisions it can make for
us. Now it's always such a grippling
effect when people talk about AI.
Sometimes it's so overwhelming you start
to think is this actually reality or is
this just a colorful aspect of our brain
some sense of creativity um in our
aspect of thinking or rather of defining
where this view or rather this flow of
technology is going to. Now I say this
because a couple of years ago I was in
the Nether Netherlands and we part of
the conference besides speaking was
understanding what is AI and what is
not. Um a couple of interesting
observations were made. Um we had to
turn down a couple of websites which
were AI powered apparently. But what I
realized in that moment is when people
argue they actually default to their you
know natural home language. Now being
the only South African there, it was
quite interesting that at some point I
was not part of the conversation even
though I was the one that probably said
whatever they were speaking about is not
actually an AI
improvision. Needless to say, I was not
happy. So the organizers decided to make
it up for me. They would walk me down to
one of the famous pubs in the
Netherlands. Now, as I walked in there
and introduced myself, to my surprise, I
was presented with beer, which is
probably one of the best responses to
introducing myself has gone. And only to
find out that my name actually sounds
quite close to one of the most famous
beers in the Netherlands. Now this is
not a unusual thing for me because um in
the African speaking um communities when
I introduce myself and if I say my name
too quickly I'm often being asked are
you okay or are you scared of something
and so this is really such a common
thing for me to um get when I introduce
myself now let's just make it clear my
name is Tabang as I introduced myself
earlier but my name actually in Satuana
means to be happy. Now I'm not sure if
my dad was happy but I know I was the
firstborn son and I think he must have
had a lot of thoughts but internally he
might have been happy. Now I grew up in
the south uh Suetu which we call the
southern township um all the way in
South Africa all the way in
Johannesburg and one of the key things
about me is I've always been a child
that like to break things apart. Now,
we'll get to breaking things apart and
how that story ended. But I've always
thought of things in minute pieces and
how this big representation of
something, what are the what are the
little pieces that contribute to it or
rather that build up to it? And this is
one of my first targets. I mean, I know
my dad had one of this and one of the
questions I used to ask him is, why do
you carry such a heavy object on your
belt? And for some reason, people with
who had pagers had a very unique way of
walking. And I'm hoping it's not the
weight of the pager that was at hand. Um
my other target was the cell phone,
right? And um for the young ones, they
probably are amazed. What the hell is
this? But actually, these are the phones
that were in use a couple of years ago
or rather in our time as they say. And
I've always asked myself, cool. So just
with this device I can make a call. But
for me I think one of the targets that
has always been in my mind was this
little baby right here. This was like
the 72 in. This was like the plasma of
back in our days. And I've always asked
my grandmother, what is behind this TV?
Like why is it so big at the back in my
mind? Are the actors inside the TV? So
there was quite a lot of things that um
happened. Needless to say um for my
efforts of being good at breaking things
apart, I am still buying TVs for my
grandmother or rather even my whole
family. Now clearly I had a big big
talent of breaking things apart. So what
better way to break things apart than to
go break humans. And I went to go study
medicine. Um studied medicine which was
quite interesting. Um because it seems
like putting things to back together was
actually the more important part rather
than the breaking apart which started to
seem a bit boring for
me because unlike my fellow colleagues
that flatlining sound for me was
probably one of the most interesting
things because I used to ask myself cool
how does this how do all these senses
work? How how does it pick up that
somebody or unfortunately has passed on?
I mean, what are all these things that
are used to keep the person alive? And
then I did the switch. Now, if you're
from South Africa, you know the famous
switch. The famous switch is when you
leave vets or the rather the University
of Vet Vat and you walk down the road
and you talk to the guys at UJ to let
you in.
And upon completion of my BSc computer
science, I've always asked myself, if we
look at Africa and if we look at it
apart, before we bring it together, what
does Africa actually have to offer? What
do we have to offer to the world besides
the natural minerals and all of those
wonderful things that they usually see
us for? What do we have to offer this
world? and what how does the world
actually see us now when we speak
especially around the concept of AI
Africa is normally seen as the baby you
know still going into this phenomenon
and understanding where this AI thing is
taking us but it's strange because I
recently read that the third highest
daily use of chat GPT is coming from
Kenya now I'm not sure what the Kenyans
are searching for but clearly it means
we are quite quite immersed in
technology right we are using it it is
in our hands we are utilizing it whether
we searching for the right things that's
not important for now um and a couple of
things that has always struck strung
true to me is when I look at some of the
um patents or rather new found new
founded AI startups that are coming up
most of them are in the European
countries Asian countries and I always
ask myself where are we where is Africa
in this and often it's not even part of
anywhere right it's probably down below
the rest of the world which for me
presents a unique opportunity I've
always said that when you don't have
much that's where you actually produce
some of the best innovations simplicity
is key now I'll get to why I say that a
bit later now Africa is actually not
that behind I mean yes we don't have all
the fancy resources that most other
continents have. But Africans have
always found a way using technology of
course to work around their problem. I
mean if you look at where the African
fintech space is right now, you'll see
quite unique um products coming out of
um Africa. Things like Empessa, the
ability for us to move money between
different individuals just by using
their cell phone number. a gamecher in
terms of using money across different
continents ac across different regions
even. Now the picture becomes clearer if
we look at just fintech revenue growth
just between 2021 and projected between
2030. You will see that Africa is
actually coming there right Africa has
the potential with its fintech products
and it's with its fintech usage to
actually be part of the global player
within fintech. Now it's important to
understand that fintech is not really AI
right so we need to understand that
because quite easily we start to
introduce tools and we introduce
processes and we see it as AI but what
does AI have to offer that we could
leverage knowing that we're quite there
we've we've been using technology to
some degree we found ways around some of
our problems with products like
Impessa but if you take a also look just
within the continent. You'll see that um
the country I'm in South Africa actually
has a number of companies that are
already specializing in in the AI space.
So the question is clearly we are
immersed in this AI cheese or rather
this AI
space but where does the future live for
us? I mean, what does AI present to us
that will potentially help us be in a
better space or potentially help us be a
global player as a continent? Now, I say
this because one study um looked at some
of the international market sizes um
specifically in Africa and where they
projected to be. And if you just look
just between 2020 and 2030, you'll see
an almost 17% jump or rather 17 times
jump in terms of the market size in
terms of investment and this is all in
billion dollars. So clearly there is
something that someone is seeing for
them to invest so much in this market.
But the question has always been is this
growth synonymous with what the
potential it has for Africa and is it
growing Africa? Not just the technology,
not just the AI markets, but is it
actually making an impact? And if we
take a closer look at everything we do
um in Africa, you look at some of our
problems, right? This is a problem that
we have a lot and I think this is
probably a global problem. Now applying
or rather going to your home affairs
where you get your ID or your passport
is probably seen as one of the most
dreaded life experiences you could ever
have. So if you lost your ID actually
it's not about your ID being lost. It's
I have to go stand that queue again. And
I say this because in trying to solve
some of our problems, especially in the
African context, we have a few
guardrails that you know the politics,
the tax laws, the finances, all these
red tape measures that don't allow us to
actually look at the system and change
the system, but rather we overengineer
the problem. I say this because one of
those problems that I just showed you
now if you look at some of the
innovations or rather the thoughts
around how we going to solve the
queueing problem at home affairs it's we
should get a ticket system or maybe we
should hire more people or maybe we
should open more home affairs offices.
Now I'm not disputing any of these
options. These are great options but
sometimes right and sometimes as this
picture shows you we are not really
looking at what the problem is. I say
this because one of the conversations
that I've had with a few delegates from
the home affairs um aspect is how do we
get rid of these cues? How do we make
sure that people you know either come in
at certain times and everything? I mean,
they've tried it with booking a session
or booking a doing a booking on the home
affairs website. Great innovation, don't
get me wrong. It does solve the problem,
but is it actually making the impact?
Because if you go to home affairs now, I
kid you not, the queue is probably two
times as worse than it was 5 years ago.
Now, we got to interesting conversation
as I said where we spoke about ticketing
systems and of course there were quite a
few tenders involved and discussed it.
So one of the questions I asked them
is if we know when someone's born right
and we know the age at which they
qualify for an ID or a passport or
whatever it is why then do they need to
start an application? Now when I said
this couple of people must have thought
um I might have drank too much coffee or
I might be lacking some sleep. But my
view was if we know when someone was
born and if they qual at an age at which
they qualify for an ID why can't we
automatically kickstart the process?
Now this is a common ID or rather the
new ID um design we have in South Africa
and it's a brilliant innovation but for
me are we solving the problem because if
we technically auto process or rather
auto initiate this application process
and again this is probably not a problem
that could just solve Africa's problems
this probably something that could solve
even global problems around these things
like ids and all these documents that
are quite important of course as
individuals to have.
Now all I did there was started to think
differently and then they asked me how
is it that you got to this point where
you thought about this thing just in a
different way right just beyond over the
ticketing systems and all these
innovations and mind you they might have
some effect but for me does it solve the
Q problem so if you look at South Africa
so I stories
Now having struggled childhood.
and I think we can all agree that is
some innovative thinking some different
way of thinking about a common problem
and this is not actually a new thing
where you'd see it in uh Nigeria where
we have farmer wings which is used to
deliver medicine across remote areas or
other regions that are quite difficult
to get to or rather deliver to around
Nigeria. We also see it with Project
Commulus where we are able to produce
water and I think this is in Morocco if
I'm not mistaken where just using the
air you are able to produce drinking
water. Now I don't know about you but
that's some groundbreaking stuff not
just continentally but actually
globally. So it's quite clear that South
Africa has made its mark to some degree
or rather Africa actually and for me is
with this immense potential with this
immense creativity um with this immense
opportunities and clearly the usage of
technology how are we using that to rise
above where the continent is or rather
to rise above our current circumstances.
Now sometimes when you take a deeper
look into what our problems are or
rather what are the hindrances for to
our success in our uprising as I call it
which is the uprising that AI provides.
Sometimes it's actually how we see
ourselves. I often think as a continent
and as people within the continent, we
sometimes see ourselves below par or
needing to do over and above to be at a
level like the rest. And for me, that
speaks to a mindset problem more than
anything. And as we think that way, we
actually shape how people see us. We
probably think we are not good enough.
Yet all these global players are
investing in our space and clearly using
some of our resources to activate some
some of their biggest processes. I mean
the likes of China, you've seen it with
Chinese cars revolution where they've
brought in a couple of African
innovators to come in and build these
things and actually pioneer what we see
now which is a revolution in the car
market industry.
Now in when you take a look and I think
I said this earlier when you take a look
at some of the what we call your natural
minerals or rather um earth minerals as
they say um you'll see that Africa
actually holds about 30% of the world's
earth minerals. I put this slide because
on one of my visits down to Vic Falls,
um I met up with one of the chiefs there
and we had a long conversation of course
about some of the problems that Africa
faces. But we got to talk about minerals
and all of this and we started thinking
about cool. So we have all of these
minerals that you know rich and clearly
we exporting out to the
world then which yes is profitable for
us to some
degree. These products or the minerals
then get repackaged or packaged into
some product or rather finished product
whether it's a car part or in this
instance a car.
then we buy it
back into the continent or into the the
country. Now, don't know about you, but
something doesn't seem right
there. The question then is, are we not
seeing our potential? Are we not
recognizing the power that we actually
have? Are we not seeing the concept of
uniting more than anything? And I say
this because this is not a new
phenomenon. Many other countries or
rather even continents have changed
their position. You look at China's
growth where it is now. China took an an
approach that looks at serving China
first before it even serves the
international market. And for me, yes,
that took a couple some balls to do, but
it actually speaks true to making
solutions that work for you before you
serve the global market. And I'm sure
you've seen with some of the innovations
I spoke to earlier, some of the problems
that are being solved there are actually
not just African problems, but because
we had a pos position that we don't have
much resources, creativity, resources,
access to things like AI allows us to
come up with these things probably at a
much faster rate than we would have a
couple of years ago. You see where China
is, where it's probably also seen as the
global factory now, right? And you see
then this turnaround in just the mindset
has put China probably neck and neck
with a couple of the European countries.
So much so that it's gotten a couple of
weeks shaking or rather a couple of
mouths talking over way too much more
than usual. Now the world is normally
seen as your oyster as people like to
say it. But if we just center around
South Africa, my question is what is the
world doing to grow Africa to grow
Africa's potential? What besides the
financial impact is it actually seeing
us as part of the bigger
table? Because
sometimes all it takes for something to
stand out is an opportunity to just be
put on the board. Because as Africans we
always embrace what they call the spirit
or a sense of Ubuntu in our country. But
I think a spirit and a sense of
simplicity and that makes us unique to
some degree. But also it affords us or
rather it challenges us to look within
the door and understand where is our
key. How can we unlock what's behind the
door for Africa? Now, whether it's a
united Africa, whether it's a united
currency for Africa, those actually are
not conversations to focus on. For me,
we should focus on the goal. What do we
want to achieve as a
continent? Do we want to actually be
part of the bigger table and not just
consumers, but rather actually producers
on the bigger table? Now if you look at
just AI adoption in Africa, these are
figures that tell you that this is not a
phenomenon that's actually new to us. We
have already invested some degree of
companies and investment even in
learning spaces whether it's
universities and even in some primary
and high schools where we starting to
actually talk about AI and the
opportunities it provides. Now if you
look at just the SA intelligence market
as very similar to the one I saw you
guys saw earlier just in the next 10
years we're probably looking at close to
about a 72 million rand difference in
terms of just a market that's there and
that's available for us to tap into.
Now we need to step back and actually
ask ourselves like deep within our
minds, our consciousness, really ask
ourselves, do we reimagine how people
see us? Are we potentially putting
ourselves behind the queue or rather
behind the seat?
Do we need to start thinking differently
about who we are or what Africa
represents and the immense potential
that is behind it? Because I I sometimes
think that we need to shy away from all
the fluff and big words around AI and
actually start to put our hands there
play put our hands get our hands dirty
and actually play with these tools and
and um resources that are available to
us. But my question then goes back to
something that I asked earlier. What
does AI mean to you? If you're an
African, what are what are these
opportunities that resources are there?
Creativity is clearly there. What does
it mean to you? And if you're in the
European
market, what can you do to make sure
that Africa stands on its own two feet,
not just as a participant, but as an
active player in the market? Now what AI
means to all of us is quite different,
right? Whether it enhances the ability
for us to think through um certain
situations. We all need to start
thinking around really really does AI
give us everything we need or we've
actually had everything we need but AI
just unlocks that potential or rather
makes us see that we've actually been
putting ourselves in the back of
everything. Now I always say the world
is really your oyster and it's really a
picture best defined by what it means to
you. My name is Tbang Lewaba and I hope
you enjoyed this talk. But over and
above everything the most important
thing is on X you can find me on
TL_aba and I work at BBD software as a
senior software engineer as an as well
as an R&D engineer. I hope you enjoyed
this talk. Thank you.